i the prime minister's even up to ask me
to go on nobody has to ask me to go out
and defend the prime minister i will do
it if i think he's being unfairly
attacked
[Music]
hello and welcome to women with balls
where i katie balls speak to today's
trailblazers
my guest i was born in liverpool to an
irish catholic father and a protestant
mother
at the age of 16 she left school and
soon after trained as a nurse at
warrington general hospital before
starting her own business a child
daycare service for working parents
she then made her move into politics
firstly as an advisor to oliver lepman
and then in 2005 she won hezy in mid
bedfordshire with 11th as a majority in
parliament
she quickly made waves as a politician
willing to speak her mind describing the
tory leaders david cameron and george
osborne as two arrogant posh boys with
no passion to want or understand the
lives of others
she also made history as the first
sitting mp to appear in reality
television through i'm a celebrity
getting out of here leading to her brief
suspension
a best-selling novelist she joined the
department of health in 2019
and was appointed minister for mental
health and patient safety
but her biggest promotion came last year
when boris johnson named her as a new
culture secretary
since taking on the role she has
regularly made the news for her bid to
rid the arts and media world of snobbery
and elitism and is now charged with
steering the online harms bill through
parliament the privatization of channel
4 and what happens to chelsea football
club and that's before we get to the bbc
all while finding time to defend the
prime minister from criticism my guest
today is nadine doris
nadine thank you for joining us today on
this podcast um you've been on a list
for some time so we're very happy to
have you in the room um on this podcast
we tend to begin by asking everyone the
same question which is was yours a happy
childhood as i mentioned you grew up in
liverpool
yeah it was um
it was
a difficult childhood we were incredibly
poor um my father was
quite ill
and um there was not kind of like the
welfare state benefit system that there
is today
so it was a tough childhood actually
very tough
and
i could recount you know dozens of
stories but sometimes i feel it just
sounds like i'm saying oh you know we
had no shoes but you know we didn't and
it's kind of i do remember hiding under
the sink from the red man and um yeah
when the red man came so it was a tough
childhood
yeah you grew up on a council estate and
i wondered at that time um what was the
politics of liverpool i mentioned your
parents different religions were you
very aware of oh so aware of it
so aware of it i remember even as
a
at three years of age
my grandmother
and my mother arguing because my mother
hadn't been churched after having my
brother
and it was it was very much a divide
between the catholic side of my father's
family and the protestant side of my
mother's family i mean i don't think
people today would actually who weren't
aware of what it was like in liverpool
in 1960s would really understand what it
was like but it was
it was very much you know political
everybody in liverpool in those days
spoke about
religion uh politics or football it was
the burning passion of conversations
and
and i've you know i've said i remember
as a child lying on the floor falling
asleep while those conversations raged
over my head so i was kind of born and
brought up in politics and interestingly
in football uh because my
great-grandfather was one of the
founders of everton football club and um
yeah and religion is
is those were the three
kind of things that i grew up um in and
were imbued by as i grew up
and did you start to identify as a tory
from a young age or when when you were
single as politics redeveloped
that's really interesting actually
because
i went through a
what am i i remember standing in our
front step while our neighbor sue
manning was scrubbing her step
and it was an election it was in the
early 70s and i remember asking her who
are you voting for i wasn't old enough
to vote and she went um
i'm voting for uh we're going to vote
for labour because they're they're the
party of the workers
and and i said to my mum who i think
this mama i asked who are we voting for
and she said we're voting for the party
of the family the tories
and so already there were those those
divisions it might have been sue
actually you said she was going to vote
for the
party of the family but there was
definitely that you know one's the party
for the family and once the party for
the workers and that was i remember
being aware of that
from quite a young age but
when right to buy came in it was really
margaret thatcher that that shaped my
political ideology because when right to
buy came in
we
for my family and many families in our
councillor's day that was literally like
somebody from westminster putting a hand
into our councillor's day and lifting
people up and you know everybody had
packing cases divided in their gardens
and everybody's front door was the same
color that the council painted it which
was a dark green
and as people began to buy their houses
through right to buy the packing cases
were ripped up the front doors all
became and everyone's individuality came
into the street
and you'd see flowers being planted in
what was just a little strip of land in
front of the garden in front of the
house the metal railings that were just
taken away and it was
watching that i remember seeing that
transformation i remember asking
my dad why the people across the road
were taking the packing cases up that
were divided in their garden from next
door he still they bought their house
this week they're putting in a fence
and it was that and i think labor tony
blair's ideology the ideology of new new
labor to remove right to buy
for me was kind of why would you do that
why would you remove that whole layer of
social mobility that that ladder out for
people
and so that really is what formed my
made me a tory was right
um at 16 you leave school and you train
as a nurse um
lots of obviously your colleagues on
this uh pocos come on they talk about
their time at oxbridge and i wondered
when you were at school was university
like pitched as an option was it was
never really on on the table no it's
interesting actually because um i
remember
one of the boys from my school going to
i used to get the bus and he was on the
bus and i knew it was his last day and i
still said where are you going to and he
went i'm going to oxford
and i went where's that i had no idea
what it was i had no idea where it was
and he was going to so i remember um and
my mum saying to me his mum and dad are
really proud he's going to oxford and i
remember thinking how did he do that how
did he how did he manage to do that i
had no idea what even a university was
at that point nobody did university was
not something that was talked about
you went to falls if you wanted a good
job you went to work affords on nights
and you train as a nurse and and then
you go on to spend a year in africa and
you come back and you start your own
business
i i was well obviously i was i had my
eldest daughter and i was still nursing
but then we decided to start um i
decided to start my own business yeah
which was it was at 1990
91
yeah 1991 that i decided and it was
again very much you won't remember
because you're too young but
the the issue of women not returning to
work was huge something like 92 percent
of women did not return to the workplace
when they had a baby
and
and the reason why was because there was
absolutely no child care and no child
care support
and
and there was a huge problem of benefit
in kind taxation if employers tried to
assist women to get them back into the
workplace and so i decided to establish
my own consultancy at the time which was
company kids
and and it was just it was i was just
had the right idea it was a it was a
business i started from an original
concept of my own concept but it was the
right place in the right time because
i literally just went around
organizations where i knew they had
a high number of very valuable females
who were going to go maternity leave and
not return so glaxo pfizer smith klein
beecham as it was at the time shell
procter gamble
goldman sachs and and they were i never
did a days advertising i just went into
each of those businesses
tailored a support package for their
their women so when they went on
maternity leave they became my
responsibility until they returned and
it was our job to get their child care
in place
and it just went from the word of mouth
from one sheep executive to another and
then i sold it to bupa in 1998.
um the year three daughters was it was
your experience of motherhood um did it
impact that a lot in the sense that you
were kind of thinking yourself about how
you balance that with a career yeah no
it did and it was very much you know
having a family myself and
still wanting to have a career myself
and realizing my options were incredibly
limited it was a bit of a shock to me
it was kind of wow i didn't realize it's
going to be so hard
to
the expectation is that i should
always be a stay-at-home mum
and that's what really helped me to to
kind of have the idea of the business
um that's a bit of a cliche really
doesn't it
really i mean i still think there's lots
of people who aren't having children
because they just don't think they can
it's i think there's lots of women still
feel as though it's career versus
children yeah very much so so
um
so at what point do you start to think i
want a career in politics because you
sell the company um and uh at that point
yeah it was literally i remember sat in
the first thing i mean my husband was
driving and i was reading the telegraph
newspaper and it was something ken clark
had said which absolutely infuriated me
and i remember my husband saying to me
well instead of complaining from the
outside why didn't you get involved and
do something from the inside you've sold
the business now you can do whatever you
like and i thought you're right as he
often was about most things i thought
you're right yeah i can so and i just um
i
joined the party
um
met a few people and did you just know
it be the tory party at that point yet
so yeah that was when i kind of yeah it
was pre-97 i joined the party and i
think
96
or 97
and it was when the party was completely
just you know disintegrating
and and i
yeah i knew i mean it was
i read an interview that tony blair had
given in the sunday times in a magazine
and i realized now that was a big
interview at the time for him and it was
a really good interview but again it
just came back to social mobility and
and things like right to buy for me and
of course everything margaret thatcher
had done i mean she was a hero on you
know where i came from so the fact that
she in what are now called red wall
seats like mine i remember a car coming
round with a loud speaker on the top um
during the election and kids running
after it shouting margaret that to
margaret thatcher you know you just that
kind of reach that she had into
backgrounds where people like me came
from
that was the kind of person the party i
wanted to be a part of
now so you're root to politics let's go
for it because you stood in one seat
before you won your seat
and you also advised um oliver letwen
how how was that experience was it a
meeting of mines
actually olive and i got on really
really well i i really liked oliver
um he was
as individuals go he's more scattered
than me but i really liked oliver yeah
never got on very well so you enter
parliament what surprises you
it's just about everything
and yeah i've been working there but
i've been downstairs in the shadow
cabinet blog for four years but wow just
about everything
it was i remember john hayes saying to
me um
in the tea room he said do you know who
you remind me of
addison he said you're like alice in
wonderland in that book you look like
you've just fallen down the hole in the
matata's tea party and you're blinking
and looking at what people are saying
like we're talking a different language
and he said and you're right just like
the matata's departure
and it really that's what it felt like
to me people were talking in alien
concepts and languages and it was just
it was a bit it was as far removed from
normal as anything could have been did
you feel like you didn't belong there or
did you yeah yes very much so
very much like what have i done
and this is just not a normal place to
be yeah and even in terms of colleagues
on your own side yeah yeah it was just i
realized that
there were some very interesting
characters around
um there's a leadership contest uh you
initially bought david davis i didn't
have any yeah um then i think you would
draw
your support for david davis
so i did there was something that
happened really it was uh tactics used
to
discredit david cameron
and which i wasn't really happy with and
so
i just didn't want you know i was
bringing you into politics i did not
want to be a part of that
so it was which is really interesting
because now it would look as though it's
just small frying
yeah a lot has changed um how did let's
talk about david cameron briefly as
leader
because i mentioned the introduction
obviously your comments about david
cameron and george osborne which
spread far and wide but i wanted so
you're in parliament it's a strange way
i think they kind of hit a pulse at a
time
i think it was
they did i mean i was shocked at the
pickup
because it was huge but i think it was
almost though i'd said something that
people were thinking
but i'd be the first person to say it
what happens when you say that do do you
have people calling you you know linked
to them or even the people themselves to
say
you shouldn't have said that or do you
find actually you're just in political
siberia and and people aren't reaching
out no i was actually i regretted
calling them um
posh boys in a way
because
it kind of
it was
it was not really what i meant
what i meant was probably privileged
boys and i should have used that word
rather than posh boys i think
what i was trying to say was that
actually i think
in politics people do need to be able to
relate
to the lives of people that you're
governing for
and i felt with at the time with dave
and george
as they
they weren't actually doing that
and and i may have been wrong you know
maybe they were relating but didn't look
as though they were everything looked
very
everything i saw
was irritating me because it was almost
boys boarding school tight behavior very
chummy and very
very jokey and
and it wasn't really it didn't seem
serious enough to me or
relatable enough to certainly from the
background that i'd come from and the
problems that people living in that i
knew and still know today and i'm still
friends with people i was at school with
and it didn't feel to me as though they
were really relating to the problems of
the day in a serious way
and
that's just what it was really and it
was i probably just said i shouldn't
have said it but i did
it seems in your career in politics
you've often done things a little bit
differently and and i don't think that's
perhaps not knowing the rules are
actually just choosing to do things your
own way um i think it's probably a bit
of my autism as well to be honest so
it's kind of like that that definitely
comes into play but it's um yeah i do
but
yeah my special advice has a hard time
so i do do things a bit differently
um
one of those was i'm a celebrity which i
did mention in the introduction um and
you go on the show at the time you're a
backbencher and but there's a big for
all while you're on it i think you're
suspended half halfway through or while
you're on the show
um
is that the case do they tell you that
you're facing suspension from the tory
party you're having the whip removed
sorry yeah actually the person the first
person i spoke to when i was in
australia was fraser nelson
so he was the first person to get
through to me when i got out of the
jungle i think fraser told me
so um
which is interesting but what was more
interesting was um was what fraser told
me which is that the chief whip at the
time was denying that he knew i had gone
and he was doing it from his sun bed in
the bahamas
so
you know fraser nelson told me that
and um and i was kind of slightly
shocked because the chief webb did know
i was going i'd gone to see him i'd had
a meeting with him
and told him
and so i was kind of slightly stunned
that he was saying that he didn't know
i'd gone
and that um and i was stunned that
fraser had told me that he was doing it
for his son ben obama's because of
course parliament was on recess at the
time
and i missed no government votes while i
was away at all
but of course you know the spin and the
way it's portrayed was that i deserted
government and
which wasn't the case at all chief
weibachi uh the former chief where
benjamin mitchell actually came up to me
and apologized
a little while afterwards and said i'm
sorry but you know it was all very very
uh very pressured at the time and he
apologized for having said that he
didn't know but he didn't know
um you've also appeared on channel 4 and
a few um of their kind of documentaries
back in that period too and i just
wondered
for you do you think it's important it's
one of the things you're trying to do is
to show the public
more of what politicians do
is that when the driving forces or i
think at the time i just found
opposition so utterly boring
and parliament to be fair
at the time you got to go to australia
right so yeah just did more interesting
things now at this point i wonder in
your career
opposition back bench but i also wonder
in the sense that because you are
speaking your mind because you are
facing things like that suspension
do you think that you're almost destined
for life on the back benches are you
imagining were there points when you
thought you're never going to be in
government oh i never never really
intended to be ever
so
it was
i thought i got into politics too late i
think i was 49 when i became an mp
and i thought it was definitely a
younger person's
job to be you needed to be in there from
your 20s and i realized i had you know
i've been a life in business and nursing
and healthcare and i just didn't think
that getting into
government was
my destiny at all it was to be a
constituent cmp and to um to be about
venture
boris johnson becomes prime minister and
he has he was he a friend of yours early
on in
when did you kind of say boris and i
shared an office near to each other in
um norman shaw north when i was first an
mp and we kind of struck up a friendship
from those days and i just found him and
whereas whereas in my first days as an
mp
a lot of
the mps who were there were were very
stuffy and
not all were friendly
boris was just incredibly helpful
incredible he spoke to everybody the
same whether you know you were me from
my background or and had no idea not
clue what was going on the time or you
were somebody who was you know an
academic you just spoke to everybody
exactly the same and i kind of
appreciated that and i remember having
some constituents down and they weren't
you know because they just met him and
he took them into his office and he made
them a cup of tea and and he was just
like just such a nice guy and yeah
really got on well with him and i always
found it quite funny actually because it
was like you know you know our
backgrounds couldn't have been at the
time i thought more different i've since
learned there actually his background
was not
um the amazing background that he's
portrayed as being you know another posh
boy he actually had it very tough as a
kid as well
so forrest johnson becomes prime
minister and then you are on the
ministerial ladder first in the
department of health
and
and
in terms of that brief i mean you were
under secretary and then moved up to
minister estate so during that period
what do you have to change about
yourself do you what is what is the
biggest change from moving back venture
to minister in terms of how you approach
politics oh it's i mean it's huge it was
um
and i think the hours that you have to
work as a minister were
certainly a shock
it's
it's seven days a week
um
maybe not as intensive as it is as such
a state but it's certainly you know it's
quite full-on and of course i was in
health and we had the pandemic in 2020.
so
i was there right in fact i walked into
matt hancock's office and was stood at
the other side of the desk when he got
the phone call and we knew what we were
dealing with with covid so it was to be
in health as a minister throughout the
covered pandemic
was um
yeah that was
that was just full-on it was like there
was no such thing as a life it was
working from early in the morning till
late at night seven days a week
what point was that when when um matt
hancock got that phone call it was on
the thursday and then i was diagnosed on
the friday
and and i was told by professor keith
willis he phoned me that night
his first two words i probably
can't um always in maths actually
so there was a bit of a shock because um
nobody expected
you know anybody that they knew to get
it
and uh keith basically told me i was
patient zero i was the first person in
the uk to be tested and diagnosed who
had not been abroad
and they now knew at that moment they
were looking at something far more
serious
so it was that kind of like i knew just
a few days before that we were dealing
with something from abroad that was
being brought into the uk
but
just like 24 hours later we knew that it
was actually people within the uk
spreading between so it was it was a
a bit of a it was a bit of a difficult
time for us in health at the time
because then of course we all started
going down with it one after the other
and i'd been to the international
women's day uh lunch with the prime
minister and lots of other members of
the cabinet so yeah
yeah suddenly are you getting lots of
messages from people about covert
contacts at that point
gosh i mean it was we hadn't even got a
testing regime at that point we hadn't
got we didn't have a test that we could
you know use mass tests between
individuals it was
every day was and as soon as i was fit
to be back at work i was back at work
where we were doing exactly that
my job was nose combing infections in
hospitals and which comes under patient
safety because it was you know a bit of
a
why is it that people are going into
hospital without covid and we've got
people in ppe and red and green areas
and everything's separated nice laced
out and people are coming in healthy and
they're still catching coverage when
they come into hospital that was my
particular uh the nightingale hospitals
you know there was it was the amount of
work that needed to be achieved in a
very short space time and we were
literally every day you know being faced
with new information new data new facts
that we had to respond to worldwide
information that was coming in about
what was happening over the world
globally not just in the uk what was
happening in our care homes what was
happening in hospitals what was
happening in community transmission what
was happening with the different
variants how the virus was mutating
there was so much to deal with and there
was you know five first ministers mats
and you know four others officers it was
just
a full-on amount of work quite the
initiation um now i want to talk about
your current brief because of course we
do have limited time on this podcast um
unfortunately um but so you're appointed
as culture culture secretary and the
prime minister appoints you are you
surprised did you have a sense that this
could be coming were you
i never quite honest i know these things
you sounded out a bit before so i was
exhausted
after two years in mental health and
patient safety i was exhausted
and so i was ready to go home
and and i told them that and i'd given
all my clothes away to afghani women who
were being returned to the uk
i'd taken seven bin bags of clothes and
a drop off point just a few days before
and i was ready to go home and then i
got a phone call which was a lovely
phone call actually saying the car is
going to bring you over to downing
street enjoy the walk up to the front
door i was going what for he wants he
doesn't even need to speak to me or he
can just speak to me in the comments why
do i have to go to number 10
and it was definitely worth nadine just
enjoy the moment
i thought this is ridiculous because
this is early in the afternoon why am i
going up so early in the afternoon
and um yeah and it was it's a day i'll
never forget i remember being taken to a
room in downey street on my own and
still had my phone with me and my kids
were texting me and they were going mum
mum laura comes back says she's got dcms
and i was going really no no that can't
be true and they were thinking think now
what job wouldn't you take so i thought
what job would i take and i
knew very quickly which jobs i would not
take
um i definitely wouldn't have taken well
i'm not going to say and i and it was
dcms so
which is the job was that probably that
topic and i've always told laura she
promoted me yeah that's good getting out
there um
so in in that role i mean how did you
find the reaction to you receiving that
appointment because
absolutely sheer utter snobbery yeah
because it was pretty critical it was
horrendous so you had a one-handed
people saying oh nadine doris has been
picked because they want to fight the
culture wars and on the other hand you
have people saying why has she you know
been quite critical of their appointment
yeah um were you were you surprised by
it
so i wasn't surprised by it i expected
something that you know along those
lines but for one thing katie it's you
know it's an absolute fact and i hate
saying it because i hate playing the
women card
but
there are
men some men who do have a problem with
a woman from my background
achieving
because they've come from a completely
different background and haven't yet
quite achieved or probably will never
achieve
and so i'm used to that i do have to
deal with that all the time
and you know you have to look at us the
way as to campbell you know just like as
abusively tweeted about me over the
years john nicholson and yes even just i
can just sit here and list often
names to you but you kind of get used to
that
but
i suppose it was a bit of a surprise
that the left you know the champions of
people supposedly from backgrounds like
mine
then piled in and attacked someone from
my background and people who had no idea
who i was did not know me in any way so
whatsoever but knew nothing about me
i'd never heard me speak knew nothing
about me whatsoever who decided to be so
utterly abusive
and the only thing i can think is that
um and you know
we've discussed this a number of times i
think the fact that
they realized
that
i'm not i've gone there to achieve you
know i've gone there to deliver i've
taken this post up because things are
going to happen online safety bill you
know gone through a second reading
without even a vote
things going to happen
channel 4 is going to be sold the bbc
license fee is going to be reviewed very
soon and is going to be changed things
are going to happen under my watch now i
realize that over a
long period of time
not a huge amount has been delivered
from my department i'm now in a position
where i've got five bills to deliver and
this department has had five bills in 20
years
but i think they all they knew that i
was going to deliver and that was that
you know the the bills the notions of
channel 4 being sold the license the bbc
all of those things have been in the
ether for years i think there was a
sudden realization something might
happen now and i think that was part of
the attack
now let's talk about those various
things that you have to do in your job
and you mentioned the online safety bill
see second reading gone through there
have been tory mps uh
talking about their concerns you've had
steve baker recently writing an op-ed
about his and then also spectator i
think we've been pretty critical so can
we just say we've got 365 mps you've
taught you've talked about one there's
actually two you've got concerns
so you know out of 365 i don't know what
the percentage that is but it's pretty
minimal so you two up two mps so you're
pretty confident about the next stage
so i think it's important that you know
here in westminster where we're making
this podcast now
people are some people a very small
number of people are talking about
freedom of speech actually across the
country
the bill has been really welcomed
particularly by parents prospective
parents and just in the past 24 hours
the football association the premier
league the english football league have
all come out and supported but the
children's commissioner is in support of
the online safety bill and a whole raft
of stakeholders and charities children's
charities so the the very narrow
conversation about freedom of speech is
only happening here in westminster
across the country the bill has been
really welcomed and just on that point
about freedom of speech
this bill and it amazes me how many
people haven't read it and are making
freedom of speech comments on it this
bill
actually protects and enhances freedom
of speech
from what it was before so before and
i'll give you an example we were
dependent on the 2003 miscommunications
act in the 1988 act i think it was
and
so do you remember the robin hood
airport
the guy who says get a bomb ribbon head
airport he was arrested he was charged
he was convicted that wouldn't happen
today because that tweet he sent out was
obviously a joke that wouldn't happen
today under the new bill now he'd have
to improve
beyond reasonable doubt within a court
that that tweet was intended to cause
serious harm
and so that wouldn't even happen now the
bill has actually enhanced freedom of
speech
and and has made the situation
far better than it was before so those
people who were talking and one of the
criticisms that has made to me is you're
giving nick clegg and mark zuckerberg
more powers they have all the powers in
the world they want right now i couldn't
possibly concede them more power they
have total power they are the arbiters
of free speech
they decide what content
gets left online and what gets taken
down they decide who they're going to
slap a fake news notice on or whose
podcast they'll take down or whose
youtube videos or which journalistic
content they will allow or won't allow
on their sites they are the arbiters of
free speech we've changed that so that
actually comes back to
to
to enforcing free speech
as a principle and not something that's
decided by somebody on the west coast
now if you'll forgive me being a small
westminster minority just for one more
question um on there and and i do think
like broadly lots of people do support
lots of things in terms of self-harm
lots of parts but on that just that
freedom of speech element i think what
critics say maybe two in the tory but it
was more in the media
we'll say is well why in the media
because the media's got carve outs the
media has huge journalistic protections
and it didn't happen yeah and
and this is i suppose just if i put one
senarity i think one of the concerns
this idea that if all these you know
internet giants
feel as though it is their duty to now
do this and they've got uh they might
feel incentivized to take down more
articles to take natural posts because
they have to and with the bill they have
to be transparent and consistent
so with the
the relationship that ofcom will now
have with these tech giants they have to
to show ofcom what the basis is that
they will be doing that is on
and they will have to be consistent
across the board and they can't take any
content down unless they particularly
journalistic content until they've
informed a journalist that they're going
to take it down tell them why they're
going to do it give them a right of
robust appeal and when they make their
decision on that peel be consistent on
those decision making so
as the situation is now they can take
anyone's content down whenever they want
they will not be able to do and they
don't have to reply so you know they
took something down that you they decide
to remove our podcast or they decide to
remove something that you've written
they don't have to tell you they're
removing it they don't have to tell you
why and they don't have to respond to
you when you ask them why
under this build they will have to do
all of those things just a final thing
on that so if we take
okay let's take 2018 boris johnson wrote
an article which was quite controversial
at the time uh where he
you know said women wearing the burka
looked like letterboxes it was an
example he gave and lots of widely
condemned that do you think under the
online harms online safety bill you
could have a situation where people
think well that is an online harm
in terms of you know no really because
it's part of public debate so public
democratic content
and
anything which contribute tributes to
public debate is not
it's it it isn't applicable that just
can't happen
no okay
um now
the final and the word intent story is
very important in this bill
so
anything that anybody does they'd have
to prove that they intended to cause
harm
so
for example somebody posting tweets
about say mozart misses a penalty
or just an example
and
when people are
writing tweets bombarding social media
posts
when those people are
putting racist and quite disgusting
comments out there they are applicable
they do apply because they are obviously
intended to cause harm they're also
illegal because they're illegal offline
so they will become illegal online
so that counts
so that really makes a difference but a
journalist writing well journalist or a
politician in the letterbox example you
don't think that's that's part whether
it's whether it's something along those
lines or whether it's the trans debate
whether people are just which is quite
live at the moment that is all part of
discourse which is part of the public
debate and that isn't applicable and
just finding where do twitter pylons
come in because i think you could take
some of these examples such as an
article and say well that's resulted in
a twitter pylon on someone why depends
on what it is yeah so a twitter pylon on
a footballer
because he missed a penalty
of racist hatred is applicable twitter
pylon on me because someone doesn't like
the online safety bill doesn't count
because that's public debate
now um has you mentioned obviously
yourself on twitter pylons i wondered
you you as we talked a little bit women
particularly but i would say
particularly in your case um and perhaps
also pretty patel would fall into this
there's a certain level of venom online
um often when you do things and has that
fed into your experience with this
online safety builder um the fact that
that you will seeing i suppose from from
the darker side of the web of the web in
terms of how people can use it to you
know
put lots of poison online
well they do i think the you know the
absolute mantra is don't look
so don't i certainly don't buy that well
you know in my job i don't have time to
i literally have time to so i now depend
on you know a team to say to me do you
want to reply to this person or do you
want to i've got no idea and when uh
when i'm told uh by
somebody in the team probably best not
switch on your phone for the next 24
hours i don't so you know i've got no i
have no notifications i don't even have
twitch on my phone anymore so
it's probably a good way to have it well
so it's nice it's on a computer but i
don't you know i just don't see the
stuff that constantly comes up um no you
seem very tough to be honest in the
sense that you do i yeah and that that i
think that's an impression that people
have of you is that you are tough and
you're not put off by things and there's
been times when the prime minister has
been under pressure and others haven't
gone out it's bad for him and i just
wanted
do you feel like you are you have you
know thick skin on the stuff or
are people
not seeing the fact that some of this
criticism does get to you
um do i have a thick skin
so i think i just tried to do what is
the right thing to do
and
yeah i mean if i'm i the premise is even
up to ask me to go and nobody has to ask
me to go and defend the prime minister i
will do it if i think he's being
unfairly attacked
so
again it's um it's quite interesting
isn't it because i've noticed that a lot
of people today tend to be kind of quite
risk of it they don't like people not
liking them
and so they'd rather not put their heads
above the parapet and that's where
social media has changed behavior
so whereas before other people would
probably quite happily give a comment to
a journalist or a newspaper in a
conversation or in a quote
right now people are more reluctant to
and i know i i know journalists find
this more they find it difficult now to
get mps to give them quotes and anything
particularly named quotes that because
everybody's scared of what the online
pylons will be or what will happen to
them or their reputations you know one
thing you know a horrible comment or
something online just goes around the
world in seconds you know
and
and so i'm probably old school you know
i'm like
65 in a few weeks so i'm just been here
a long time and so i'm i'm less
worried about my long term career so i'm
less concerned about
you know getting a bad rep or or being
attacked for supporting the prime
minister whereas i think some people
who've got a career in front of them i
think oh don't want to write the boat
just now you know so i think that's got
something to do with it yeah and i
suppose if you've been someone who has
spoken on various issues throughout your
career and you're in captain now it's
not as though you're saying well if
anything you'll be changing tech by
doing something yeah yeah no i think i
said once an interview when someone said
what would you why would you stop
supporting the problem well if i kicked
a dog obviously i'm not going to blindly
support him whatever he does but you
know it's but he's the prime minister of
the elected government i've got and i'm
a cabinet minister that is my job it is
my responsibility
to and it's part of collective
responsibility to support the prime
minister and support the government is
what i do it's what every cabinet
minister under tony blair did when tony
blair was in power and it's what i'm
doing with boris johnson
channel 4.
um then
announcement that it will be privatized
obviously had led to backlash in some
quarters some in your own party um
particularly on the one nation being
quite critical of it
there are those who say the decision to
privatize as punishment for the channel
four's coverage being too um
biased to the left um i wonder what you
say to that but also kind of what we can
expect in terms of the next steps of
this
so um you know uh child four isn't being
sold for ideological reasons i know
those criticisms will be there and
there's nothing i can do to stop people
who want to say that from saying it but
it's not
it's
you know margaret thatcher's idea to
establish channel 4
to use it as a seed bed to grow
raw talent and
independent talent and to make new
british content was the right thing to
do at the time but she also wanted to
sell it in 1988 as charles moore has um
informed me
and it's just the fact that we the state
owns a broadcaster today is kind of
quite bizarre
and
it's it's absolutely
a thatcherite policy to sell channel
four
and to allow it actually to because one
of the problems at the moment is only
seven percent of independent production
companies get their funding from channel
4. that's a tiny amount it's not doing
even what it was established to do
and channel 4 needs to raise money and
although
you know we don't pay for the day-to-day
running of channel 4 when channel 4
needs funding it comes to the government
and what we need to do to allow and if
it needs borrowings it comes to the
government
and it's you know advertising we're in a
world now
where the main funding the lifeblood of
channel 4 which was advertising now has
so many other places to go netflix is
probably about to start advertising so
that's more competition that those
advertisers that channel 4 is going to
be facing because those advertisers will
be moving to different places so we want
it to be able to to raise revenue we
want it to grow we want it to make fresh
content but you know it's not allowed to
sell its content under its present
license it's not allowed to
to produce and sell and and to grow in
that way it's just wholly dependent on
advertisers so how do we get more money
how do we let child fall survive how do
we pump funding into it we privatize it
we let it go and raise funding we don't
do what it's supposed to do it can raise
as much money as it likes and channel 4
can continue
but it will continue privately not
state-owned and the great thing about it
is is that whatever it's sold for
we'll be able i'll be able to pump that
money back into the sector particularly
into training and skills because we've
got
17 studios that i'm aware of opening in
the next 12 months film studios in the
uk but an absolute lack of trained
people and skilled people to work in
those studios so using that money from
channel 4 to train people in the skills
that we need to get them into the film
business
that's what i want to do with the money
to get it back into the sector
and it seems to me like it's a win-win
channel 4 raises the investment it wants
we get to pump money back into the
sector
why wouldn't we do that
see if some of your colleagues come
around to that
well actually just to to so
again there are 365 mps and we've done a
careful analysis of all of our mps and
we very comfortably have the number that
we need to get this through
um final two questions on the bbc and
you said that
in various kind of interviews and
comments that ultimately there needs to
be more of a focus um
i don't put words in your mouth so you
can correct me but almost
perhaps something i'm moving away from
kind of metropolitan elite to more
working class
um opportunities uh do you think they're
listening are you seeing changes yet in
terms of how the bbc approached some of
the problems that you've raised
so you know tim davey himself director
general said that the bbc has a problem
with impartiality he had to because if
it didn't why would we've had the
serrated review and the dyson review and
the 10-point plan and the
the
the announcement about how they were
going to implement that plan to tackle a
lack of impartiality within the bbc
it is a fact the bbc has a problem with
impartiality but you know don't lose we
can't lose sight of the fact that the
bbc also does a fantastic job it makes
great programming it's a global british
brand across the world everybody loves
the bbc
but that doesn't mean it's like having a
family and someone in your family has
you know a
a problem it's like pretending it's not
there
it is there and it is an issue that
needs to be dealt with and i think
there are
in terms of the longer term
outlook for the bbc you know it's a
licensed fee model that was established
in 1946 4546
it's it's completely out of date
it's
all of their convictions 76 of their
convictions 74 76 of their convictions
are women because women
quite often take the responsibility for
the household bills
it's just it's completely outdated
and so we are going to
very soon
announce
that we are um going to be looking
very seriously at the how we fund the
bbc moving forward
and and be
moving through that process to get to
the point where well ahead of the
charter renewal in 27 we are ready to
implement
a new way of funding the bbc moving
forward
so moving so it's not going to look as
it currently does just give you a scoop
there okay
so
this will be moving away from perhaps
the full tv license model that we
currently have
so the charter renewal when the license
fee model would come up is uh 2027. so
obviously that's that's into the future
we need to look that's five years away
so i've got the midtown review coming up
which will be announced very very soon
and in that we're going to be looking at
how ofcom hold the bbc to account
and then very shortly after that we will
be announcing
um other measures that we're going to
put into place
to start looking at how the bbc will be
funded in the future said that we are
well in time
to have that in place for the charter
renewal in 2027.
if the tories are still in power
yeah
um now the final question is when we ask
everyone on this podcast and i actually
really want to know your answer because
i imagine you've been given quite a lot
of advice in your time and i imagine
you've probably ignored quite a lot of
it but i could be wrong
um colleagues tell you what you should
be doing in terms of parliament and so
forth so what is the worst advice you've
ever been given
i suppose the worst advice was when i
began
as an mp and i was worried about my
daughters
and because the youngest one was still
quite young
and a lot of advice i got was oh don't
worry kids are adaptable but they're not
kids are not adaptable to their mother
receiving
abuse
or you know i had a stalker for eight
years they're not adaptable to their
mother having a stalker
and
yeah their
kids are not adaptable that's a complete
myth
i think that was the worst piece of
advice i was given thank you nadine
[Music]
you